[Musique]
françaises français dimanche prochain en
élisant le chef de l'état vous aurez à
désigner le français que vous estimez en
conscience
le plus digne et le plus capable de
représenter la france est de garantir
son destin car c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit
le président de la république ne saurait
être en effet confondu avec aucune
fraction il doit appartenir à la nation
tout entière exprimée et servir le seul
intérêt général
c'est à ce titre et c'est à cause de
cela que je demande votre confiance
cinq oppositions vous présente cinq
candidats vous les avez tous entendu
vous les avez tous reconnu leur voix
dénigrante sur tous les sujets leurs
promesses distribué à toutes les
catégories
leur appel à l'effacement internationale
de la france
ce sont les voir les promesses les
appels des anciens partisans dans quoi
qu'il puisse prétendre à retrouver le
régime tentant aussi le seul point sur
lequel s'accordent leur passion ses
montées pas mais ce n'est pas assez
car leurs contradictions mutuelle leur
clientèle inconciliables leur engagement
dans tous les sens
montre à l'évidence que les accessions
de l'un quelconque d'entre eux au poste
suprême marquerait infailliblement le
retour à l'odieuse confusion ou se
traînait naguère l'état pour le malheur
de la france
or si je là nous ont coûté assez cher
pour que nous ayons appris que dans le
monde difficile et dangereux où nous
vivons rien de valable ne peut être
accomplie sans l'adhésion profonde de la
nation à ceux qui lui commun est
essentiel
eh bien vous le savez c'est cela que les
événements m'ont amené à représenter à
travers toutes les tempêtes et par
dessus tout les intérêts et c'est au nom
de cela que vous m'avez donné votre
appui pour quoi faire
pendant la guerre après le désastre ou
le régime des partis avaient conduit
notre pays / e et privé par eux des
armes nécessaires
la résistance qui aboutit à la victoire
lors de la libération un ensemble son
précédent de réforme comme par exemple
la sécurité sociale les allocations
familiales les nationalisations les
comités d'entreprise le statut du
fermage le droit de vote aux femmes
et caetera réforme qui en nous évitant
de très graves bouleversements
remplacèrent le mauvais système du
laissez faire laissez pas ces réformes
auxquelles après mon départ
le régime des partis se disent
attends dans l'impuissance n'a rien
ajouté
et puis depuis sept ans après son
effondrement
devant la bim de la guerre civile et
devant l'imminence de la faillite
économique et monétaire commencent à la
marche en avant par l'adoption
d'institutions stables et efficace la
coopération remplaçant la colonisation
le développement planifié au profit de
tous les français de notre économie de
notre équipement de notre enseignement
de l'eau capacités scientifiques et
techniques
bref l'impulsion ans dans tous les
champs d'action ouvert à nos forces
vives au dehors par une politique
d'indépendance et équilibre l'action
menée par tous en faveur de la paix
notamment en asie où sévit une absurde
guerre
l'effort entrepris pour recoudre notre
continent déchiré
d'une part en poursuivant l'organisation
de l'europe occidentale et l'autre par
en nouant avec les pays de l'est ce des
rapports multiplier la présence
l'influencent la culture française
s'affermissent ans dans toutes les
parties de la terre s parfait s complet
gaffe sûrs que non puisqu'il s'agit
d'une oeuvre humaine mais c'est peuvre
là qui s'appelle salut et puis le début
de la rénovation peut bien être décriée
par les champions de la décadence
elle n'en est pas moins évidente et
reconnus du monde entier cependant il
faut
elles se développent et s'élargissent
davantage encore oui la république
nouvelle veut que le peuple lui donne
demain plus tard et toujours une tête
qui en souhaitent une et que l'homme
ainsi mandaté pour répondre du destin
notamment dans les jours grave porte lui
même ses responsabilités oui la
république nouvelle veut que notre pays
continue d'avancer dans la prospérité
suivant ce que prévoit la loi du plan de
telle sorte que les revenus de tous les
français s'accroissent avec le produit
national sur la base d'une économie
concurrents avec celle de tous les
autres d'une monnaie inébranlable et de
budget équilibré
oui la france nouvelles comme la
république nouvelles veulent que tout en
restant alliés ne nous alliés et amis de
nos amis elle ne pas petit plus cette
subordination à l'égard de la 2 qui
serait indigne d'elle et qui pourrait
automatiquement dans certains cas les
jeter dans un conflit qu'elles
n'auraient pas voulu
oui la république nouvelle veut doter la
france d'un armement nucléaire parce que
quatre autres états en antin parce que
tout le monde sachant qu'elle ne menace
personne
[Musique]
il se trouve qu'un pareil instruments
revêt pour sa défense
un caractère de dissuasion incomparable
par rapport aux systèmes d'autrefois
parce qu'il nous coûte pas plus cher et
qui nous a permis de diminuer de moitié
la durée du service militaire
enfin parce qu'à notre époque atomique
electonic raciale nous ne devons pas
priver la recherche la science la
technique l'industrie française du tout
ce qu'elles peuvent tirer et le doubs ce
qu'elles tireront pour leur progrès pour
leurs activités de cette nécessaire
entreprises oui la république nouvelle
qui a déployé pour l'union de l'europe
occidentale de grands et constant effort
en partie couronnée de succès veut que
l'édifice sachem dans des conditions
équitables et raisonnables que
l'agriculture française entre dans le
marché commun effectivement et sans que
par la suite quelques commissions dites
supranationales ou quelques vote à la
majorité puisse remettre tout en cause
que si un jour il s'agit de pain tire
une organisation politique des six la
france par l'effet de cette même
procédure ne risque pas d'être entraînée
sur notre continent dans une action
dangereuse et qu'elle n'approuverait pas
tout cela se fait
de telle sorte que jamais ne soit
étouffée aucune de nos libertés
cela se fait en conjuguant et non pas en
opposant le courant du mouvement qui
porte aux changements et aux réformes et
le courant de l'ordre qui tient à la
tradition et à la règle cela se fait
grâce aux appels que j'ai maintes fois
adressé franchement et directement à
chacune à chacun de vous dimanche ce
sera le cas puisqu'il va dépendre de
vous toutes et de vous tous que je
poursuive ou non ma mission
le 5 décembre
si vous le voulez la république nouvelle
sera définitivement établi alors elle
prendra le départ pour une autre étape
d'autant plus ardent est féconde il
s'agit que pendant le temps où je
resterai à sa tête elle redouble son
effort national et mondial qu'après moi
elle demeure normalement et suivants
céline enfin colons de l'avenir
elle procure à notre pays ce qui lui
assure aujourd'hui la dépendance le
progrès la paix françaises français
continueront la france
yves la république vive la france
[Musique]